bonjour à vous toutes et à vous tous
bonjour
jimmy notre invité en effet et thérèse
les hôtes un bonjour madame bonjour -
jours à tous et à toutes
ravi de vous avoir en studio ce matin
pour parler d'un nouveau livre que vous
venez de publier
c'est tout chaud ses sorties il ya été
publié il ya quelques semaines
alors on va d'abord vous présenter
thérèse léotin vous êtes enseignante à
la retraite ex directrice d'école osa
directrice honoraire même d'écoles
maternelles d'applications officier dans
l'ordre des palmes académiques
et puis vous êtes membre de
l'association creil match et créole
matinik le km2 association d'écrivains
en langue créole de martinique et donc
vous publiez je monte le livre à la
caméra là ma mère il ya un titre aussi
en créole c'est de l'osier amer et donc
vous n'êtes pas à votre première
publication votre premier livre vous
avez déjà publié des romans on peut
citer un bonheur à crédit ou encore la
panthère et puis aussi beaucoup de
livres pour enfants sa seconde ça compte
pour vous ça vous tient à coeur ses
livres pour enfants alors thérèse léotin
donc c'est ce livre là ma mère en créole
c'est de l'osier en mai à ses delozien
mais un oui c'est bien ça c'est paru aux
éditions avec exbrayat
j'ai un peu de mal sur le titre mais on
va on veut y arriver justement comment
sont pas par là le titre est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
pourquoi avoir choisi ce titre c'est
dosière mer et par rapport au récit en
mai avant de continuer plus avant et
j'ai fait beaucoup de traduction aussi l
etrat guy l'avant de moulière piété à je
traduis montesquieu ja vient récemment
de traduire giono un texte que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et puis boldrini
et d'autres alors pourquoi le titre de
larmes amères c'est pas ma peau au
contenu évidemment comme je lui dis et
puis pour montrer que l'élan quelquefois
sont nécessaires ah bon on va au sens de
l'histoire mais donc l'homme en créole
ça se dit d'osier oui c'est cette
deuxième même si maintenant on adore
chanter est la moins qu'à couler mais
non c'est de l'eau jamais plaisir
si nous il est vraiment des balais créé
le cas en haïti l'iqee maqam il agit pas
de problèmes qui résultent mon caddie et
kréyol il l'a et plus foncée à fondcombe
à l'effort global et vallée des loups
ballet des champions nous c'est débile
en gap allée des landais faut pas nous
en tenir
ninon lot pape nous mettez l'aider même
voté alors précisément intéressé
d'autant comment comment ça se présente
le livre justement c'est il ya une
version française
enfin voilà le texte écrit en français
et puis juste après on trouve le texte
en créole bien martinez labitid avant
mettez un page français en patrouille en
face voilà la somme assez qui fait
ki-moon en tk gadé à face comme manager
jean nadeau le lyonnais john mensah gha
des gosses à et simon entre les nids
page lightning l'a même à côté du coi en
face lui mais c'était un travail vous me
passez langue française en créole palio
pas obligé l'idée quand il quand même
goûté au contrôle et si vous mettez tout
vidé l'idea clients français aux limites
y ait écrire la houppe obligés d'occuper
nuit en tipi county plus longue mais
matt est arrivé fait mais c'est dingue
en goût au travail
google travaille comme a commencé vivier
de beaux mouvements et comment commencer
du nifff ayant donc moi dix fois qu'à la
qualité du créole en bon et tout
meilleurs et tout le temps c'est un beau
et pour mutualiser s'il ya un monier à
magalie dumas les mauvais indices ase
group
en gros quoi il a trouvé toute fin c'est
un beau tout crieur en beau ça hyper v
vendémian et de café alors ça c'est pour
la forme on parle de l'histoire
justement thérèse les hautains et là
avec la ma mère c'est delozien mer il
est question d'abord d'une enfance
heureuse
oui c'est la vie en haïti fille croit
était bien heureuse à daha d'un pays dit
benitez cavill tout ça nous vivent les
noter pythie d'italie cinéma y avait eu
la grosse clé a fait tout ça et ça c'est
dans les années que 1950 1960 ou avance
prise 1975 1950 ils vivent tout ça quoi
et puis
après la vie chamboulée mais manquaient
pas dit on pas les divas 50 petites
semaines c'est pas mon plaisir c'est
pourquoi mon envie lits ciwlt aux
acadiens
quand même c'est que ce que ça qu'à y
poser en laye des songes et personnel
est-ce que c'est des souvenirs avoue
personnel est ce que c'est votre
histoire finalement que vous racontez
votre histoire de petite fille d'un
jeune fille non un petit peu d'atouts
face à li un témoin ça va de soi c'est
moi qui l'aurai signée jeudi par le
témoin
je parle plus de ce que j'ai vécu
notamment en allant au cinéma
comment ça se passait à l'époque dans
les salles de cinéma ou le cinéma était
dans la salle
et si le cross etel interactions je
parle de ça je parle de la famille la
troupe jean gosselin des choses que j'ai
vécues mais l'histoire est le même quand
on verra de quoi ça parle ça ne parle
pas de moi et puis ce n'est pas parce
que j'ai mis jeu que je sais moi je des
laiteries ges et un autre ce n'est pas
obligatoire m'intéresse c'est le
personnage qui parle autant qu'à
l'auteur de madame bovary
il disait madame bovary c'est moi il
n'était pas un coût mais donc le dans le
prologue il ya paris baltimore le
saint-esprit
alors est ce que c'est un livre qui nous
fait voyager aussi vous n'irez pas
baltimore ah bon mais c'est un
c'est une image vous montrer que souvent
les grandes villes et les grandes villes
sont tellement mégapole si je peux me
permettre cette expression que l'on
pense que ce qui se passe dans les
petits pays n'existe pas assez souvent
les gens qui sont dans les petits pays
ne sont pas des gens
les antilles sont qui est pris dans la
langue de leur petit pays ne sont pas
des auteurs et on nous renvoie notre
petitesse haut ce qui se passe à
bâtiment aussi se passe au saint-esprit
lorca qui se passe à paris aussi se
passe au saint-esprit nous ne sommes pas
déjà diminué par rapport aux oméga poule
et c'est ce que je veux en quelque sorte
dire d'autant que le récit que vous avez
sous les yeux
c'est un récit qui a pris comme base la
vie des telles que d'un autre pays et
qu'il raconte sa misère et ses peines
dans ce qu'elle a vécu
c'était la cbi et c'est une réalité ce
que je dis c'est vrai alors on va alors
le titre donne l'impression que c'est un
livre plutôt comment dirais-je papa
triste mais enfin bon voilà qui parle
pas de chose forcément très heureuse il
ya quand même des moments parce que on
voit que d'ailleurs dans le résumé du
livre on dit que bon cette jeune fille
va avoir une sorte de chemin de croix se
veut une adolescence eu beaucoup plus
difficile voire même avec des aspects
dramatiques mais il est question d'un
chemin de croix qui finit sur une note
positive
oh oui oui parce que dans la réalité
même dans la réalité là la fille chez sa
mère mais
comme c'est moi que je mourrai ici c'est
moi qui fait les affaires d'autres j'ai
fait comme je veux et j'ai positive est
bon le suspense est aimé nager je vous
rassure donc bien parce que oui c'est un
ouvrage qui parle des maltraitances
d'abord d'abord de marita ce jet parle
un peu de la situation de notre notre
situation de la vie de notre comment
j'avais dit ça dans notre histoire aussi
n'est pas aussi bien le christ oui c'est
ça les questions de patrimoine et de
transmission de la mémoire populaire de
martinique avec ce livre donc de thérèse
léotin qui vient d'être publié dix mille
arna mer donc voilà en créole c'est de
l'osier en mer aux éditions exbrayat un
roman en français et en créole
voilà merci thérèse et hautain d'être
venu ce matin répondre à nos questions
et nous parler de ce livre est moi qui
vaut à messine alors vous le présentez
vous le présentez oui oui il faut le
dire ont donné rendez vous pour la une
présentée à présenter mais avec les
conditions évidemment scénique et je ne
sais pas si ça va se passer comme je
voudrais je suis à la médiathèque du
saint-esprit le mardi 21 20 les na'vi
qui viendra qu'au service à 24 mois et
je signe en trois ans du 23e toi et je
signe mercredi gm 4 donc à la librairie
antillaise covelli non mais avec les
conditions sanitaires j'espère prions
dieu que tout va se passer bien mais oui
oui tout se passera bien merci bonne
journée